BRADLEY WONG: Hi.
Welcome to Getting
Started with Anthos.
My name is Bradley Wong,
and I'm a product manager
at Google Cloud.
AURELIE FONTENY: And my
name is Aurelie Fonteny,
and I'm a product
manager for Anthos.
BRADLEY WONG: So
today the agenda
we're going to go
through is we're
going to start with an
introduction of what Anthos is,
we're going to go through
some of the use cases
that our customers have seen
in the last 12 months of using
Anthos, and then
we're going to go
through some suggestions on
how to get started with Anthos.
So what is Anthos?
Anthos has been around
for more than 12 months
now in the open, so
a lot of customers
have asked us, well, you
know, what is Anthos?
Is it GKE On-Prem?
Is it GKE?
Is it a container as
a service platform?
Is it a platform as a service?
Is it just a bunch
of open source tools?
Is it a bundle of different
tools that Google's offering,
or is it all of the above?
Well, probably a good way
to start with a description
is to actually start
with the statement that
describes what Anthos is.
Now, this is not all
the different use cases
the Anthos can provide,
but it certainly
is a core set of how
we think about Anthos.
So Anthos is a managed
platform for enterprises
that want faster modernization
and greater consistency
in a multi and
hybrid cloud world.
That's a lot of words, so let's
break that down a little bit.
First, managed platform.
What do we mean by that?
Well, first of all, the platform
could be consumed or subscribed
to.
Our customers can consume it
as they want, as they need,
as the requirements
grow, or they can also
purchase an upfront subscription
to offset any of the usage
charges as well.
Next, a managed platform
is also something
that takes away the toil of
actually managing it yourself.
So in that sense, Google
actually manages that for you.
So what we provide is
the capability for you
to incrementally upgrade the
capabilities of the platform
as you deem necessary.
And any updates to versions
to fix vulnerabilities,
to fix bugs, or add
new features is also
managed by Google as well.
So next, what do we mean
by application platform?
In this sense and
application platform
provides something
that can actually
host the applications
of your choice, be they
container based applications,
or they can also
be traditional applications.
Our application platform is
based on completely open source
projects.
For example, Kubernetes, Istio,
Knative, Tekton, to name a few.
Now the platform
is also designed
for enterprises in mind that
have large complex needs.
They could be
security requirements,
operational requirements,
governance requirements.
There's many, many requirements
that our enterprises need
to cater for, and Anthos
provides all those enterprises
with the capability to manage
all those needs, be they
large or small.
Next, our customers also want
the ability to have access
to faster modernization.
And with Anthos,
we provide tooling
to help our customers
to have no touch
migrations from
traditional workloads
into modern workloads.
And not just the
actual applications
themselves, but
also the platform,
and we provide tools to
help our customers modernize
the way they even manage
the platform itself.
Next, Anthos provides
greater consistency.
It's very common that across
our enterprise customers
that they may deploy Anthos in
not just a single deployment
option like in GCP,
but may want to deploy
this across hybrid
environments as well
as multi-cloud environments.
So in that sense, the importance
to have a single pane of glass
and a single
definition of how they
want security policies or even
just general configurations
need to be kept in sync
across all those environments,
and Anthos provides
methods to achieve that.
Finally, Anthos is a multi-cloud
and hybrid-cloud platform.
It's completely
software based, which
means it runs inside
on-premises data centers,
inside GCP, and also
in other clouds.
Now, Anthos those
didn't happen overnight.
It is actually a culmination
of decade's worth
of work from Google.
There's no secret that Google
has been using containers
for many, many years.
And even today, Google
still leverages the father
of Kubernetes, which
is something internally
we call [? Borg. ?] Now,
in the early or mid 2010s,
so in the 2013, 2014
time frame, Google open
sourced a project called
Kubernetes to the world, which
had a lot of the
building blocks stemming
from our experiences
of operating container
environments at scale.
Kubernetes is now one of the
most successful open source
projects in the industry.
Now, we saw that Kubernetes
although was very powerful,
it was actually
quite complex to use.
So we released in
2015 something we
call GKE, which
allowed our customers
to not have to think
about how to install
and manage Kubernetes.
We, as Google, manage it for
you, and GKE is that vehicle.
Today, on a daily
basis, we see billions
of containers deployed
onto GKE by customers
all around the world.
So then naturally in 2018,
because of the demand
to use GKE, we saw that there
was also an increased demand
to use GKE not just inside
Google Cloud's environment,
but also in all other
environments as well.
We started with GKE On-Prem
in 2018, and now with Anthos,
we expanded to multiple
different environments.
So in 2019 at NEXT, Anthos was
announced by CEO Sundar Pichai
to be generally available.
We are now 12 months into the
general availability of Anthos,
and this is where
Anthos sits today.
Anthos is now able
to be deployed
across multiple
different environments,
whether it's on
premises data centers,
in computing environments,
Google Cloud, other clouds,
and also other
Kubernetes clusters.
It also provides multiple
different services on top,
whether it's cluster
management, service management,
providing developers with more
agility through serverless
and app development frameworks,
manage operations, as well as
policy and configuration
management.
What this translates
to concretely
for the different components
and deployment options of Anthos
is this.
We now have multiple different
deployment options, so On-Prem,
bare metal, which is coming
into preview this quarter.
On GCP, we recently made
available Anthos in AWS.
By the end of this year we
also have Azure VMs becoming
available, and we
also just announced
the general
availability of Anthos
attach clusters to allow our
customers to deploy Anthos
on other Kubernetes
environments,
essentially bringing
your own Kubernetes
environment to Anthos.
Now, Anthos then provides
a single pane of glass
to manage all of
those environments,
but on top of that, provides
opinionated components
to enable additional services.
GKE for container management,
and the service mesh
to manage a service mesh
deployments powered by SDO.
Cloud Run to provide a
serverless framework,
Cloud Code to
provide IDE enabled
development environments, cloud
logging and cloud monitoring
to provide operational
visibility across all
those deployment
options, whether it's
for the platform itself
or for the applications,
as well as Anthos
config management,
which provides
consistency of deploying
policies and configurations
across all those environments.
So now let's take
a moment on looking
at what some of our customers
are using Anthos for.
So let's have a look at
some of the use cases
that Anthos has enabled
over the past 12 months.
The first one that
we find most commonly
is customers who want to migrate
and modernize their application
stacks.
Many of these
customers really want
to enable their
developers to move faster,
and their reliance on legacy
applications and their stacks
have been an impedance to be
able to offer better business
agility.
So when the promise of
containers has come up,
that was obviously a very
appealing path to choose,
but it was very difficult
for our customers to do that
without a lot of refactoring.
Anthos provides our
customers the tooling
and the capabilities to
help them migrate now
from legacy applications into
more modern container based
environments with
limited refactoring.
We also have customers
who are already
experts at using containers,
Kubernetes, and some of them
are already GKE customers,
but many of them
have also on
premises requirements
because they can't move their
workloads into cloud today,
so many of them are looking
at Anthos to actually
be that next generation
environmental container
platform.
Variety reasons why they
they're looking at that,
but the ease of use, the
consistency, the cost,
the flexibility,
all of those come
to head when they're evaluating
some of the new platforms
that they want to invest in.
And Anthos has
time and time again
been a platform of choice
for a lot of our customers
who are coming from
some existing Kubernetes
environments.
We also have a lot
of customers who
are coming from
interesting places
such as in the retail space or
in the Telco space who really
want to use Anthos as a
means to deploy clusters
and platforms in places where
you might not expect them
to exist, whether they
are inside retail stores
or locations inside ballparks,
or next to Telco 5G towers.
A lot of our
customers really want
to move analytic applications
closer and closer
to those environments too get
closer to their customers.
And finally, we have
a lot of customers
who really value the benefits
of some of the intelligent GCP
services that are offered.
Now, some of them may
not have the ability
to move those workloads
into a cloud environment
yet for regulatory or
compliance reasons,
so rather than asking
our customers to move
their data into GCP
today, what we are doing
is moving the
intelligent services
like AI and ML services into
their on premises environments,
and Anthos provides them
the ability to do that.
So also consistently across all
of those different use cases,
we have customers
who not just want
to modernize the
application stacks,
but also want to modernize
how they are doing operations.
So GitOps is a common
theme across most
of the customers using git
based mechanism software
continuous delivery
type of methods
to not just provide
continuous deployments
of their applications into
dev staging production,
but also to do that for their
infrastructure definitions
as well.
So leveraging git controls to
describe their configurations
for the platform allows them to
mutate, modify, check in check
out configurations
and be able to deploy
different versions of the
application stack at scale.
In light of that,
many other customers
then will take that
advantage and be
able to stamp out verified
and certified versions
of the configurations that
they deem as important
for different security zones
inside those environments.
Some of them may have small
stringent security settings
in, say, for example,
production of staging,
but less stringent
security environments
for development and testing.
With the GitOps model
and with configures data,
it's possible to
ensure versioning,
and it's possible to ensure the
correct security postures have
been rolled out with the right
configurations across all
those different environments.
Finally, many of our
customers are also
ISVs who want to have
the most frictionless way
to rollout their software
platform without having
to build an entirely new
infrastructure or application
stack themselves.
So Anthos offers a lot
of our ISV partners
the ability to take
their software platform
and to deliver a software as
a service, a SAS solution,
for a lot of those
solutions as well.
So with that, I'm now going
to hand over to my colleague
Aurelia who's going to
walk you through how
to get started with Anthos.
AURELIE FONTENY:
Thank you, Brad.
So I will now walk you
through the specifics
on how to get started.
So the first thing is you want
to learn more about Anthos,
so you can go and start with
the Anthos documentation, Anthos
specific Qwiklabs,
and Coursera training.
Then, the next
step after that is
to try Anthos in
your own environment.
So for Anthos running
on GCP, we currently
have a limited time promotion
where Anthos usage is free
up to a limit for
testing purposes,
and we will introduce a
self-service trial for 30 days
once the promotion runs out.
You may also
contact sales if you
want to do your own hybrid and
multi cloud proof of concept.
Once you're ready to buy
Anthos, you have two options.
You can either pay as you go,
and this is a default option,
or you can contact sales to
subscribe to a committed usage
at a preferential price point.
Now, if you want to start with
Anthos in your own environment,
we have a tutorial that's
available to explore
Anthos running on GCP.
There are two parts to it.
The first one is a prepackaged
Anthos sample environment
that includes a cluster, Anthos
features, and an online store
application.
We refer to it as Anthos
sample deployment.
The other part is a
companion tutorial,
and it helps you experience
animals through core task.
And so that's what I'm going to
demo next in a cloud console.
So for this demo, I've
created a new project.
I have navigated to
the Anthos dashboard,
and I've enabled Anthos.
So as a first time user, I'm
presented with various options
to get started.
The first one is to launch
the Anthos sample deployment.
So I'm going to go ahead
and click it and launch it.
So there are a few
configuration options.
I'm going to go and
use the default values.
Now, you need to
check the box here
that ensures that you meet all
the prerequisites to deploy
the Anthos sample.
So what that means is
you need a new project
and relevant
permissions, and you can
see more details at this link.
It's going to the
tutorial, and in there you
can also find a script that
checks that your project meet
all the prerequisites.
So I'm going to copy it, go
back to the cloud console,
activate the cloud
shell, and run it.
So it's checking that I
have the right permissions,
that we don't have any odd
policies, that the right APIs
are enabled, and that the
Anthos sample deployment has not
been previously deployed.
So great, I've passed
the prerequisites,
and I can deploy
the Anthos simple.
So from there it's going to take
about 10 minutes for everything
to be deployed,
configured, and running.
Meanwhile, you can take a
look at the Anthos tutorial.
And from there, you can
follow the guided experience.
Now, I already have
a separate project
that has been pre-provisioned
so I can start exploring Anthos.
So let's go to the
Anthos dashboard
to explore the
resources that we've
been creating with the
Anthos sample deployment.
In particular, the
Anthos sample deployment
has created a cluster with
Anthos and an application.
So you can see here
I'm in the dashboard.
I have 11 services,
and I have one cluster.
So I'm going to
view the clusters.
I can see it's six VCPU, and
I can get more details in GKE.
And from there, I can navigate
to clusters, workloads,
and in my case, I'm
interested in going
to services and ingress so that
I can check the Istio ingress
gateway service because
this is a service that's
hosting the endpoints for the
simple applications front end.
So I'm going to
go to it, and you
can see the sample application
that's been deployed.
It's called the online
boutique, and you
can explore it from there.
I'm going to add it
to a shopping cart.
You can place an order.
So now we can take a
look at the internals
for the simple
application by going back
to the Anthos dashboard and
looking at Anthos service mesh.
So I'm going to view
the service mesh.
So you can see
here I have a table
view of the key services in
the application and associated
metrics.
I can also take a look
at a topology view
for workflows and services.
So for instance, here I have
a shopping cart service.
You can see the
inbound connection,
outbound connections, and
traffic going through it,
and you can get more details.
So I'm going to go to
the service dashboard
for the shopping cart service.
We can see more
telemetry details.
For instance, the latency 50th
percentile is 54 millisecond,
and the service
status is here is none
because there are no SLO
created for this service.
So I'm going to create a
service level objective.
I'll use latency as our
indicator of performance.
I choose a very low
latency threshold
so we can see the
effect of going
past our error budget for
calendar day at 90% compliance.
Submit it.
As you can see here, we
are past our error budget,
and you can get more details.
So now we can also set up our
policies to get notification.
So in the interest
of time, we won't
go through all the tasks in
the explorer rentals tutorial.
Now, you can go
through it on your own,
and you can see that we've gone
through the first four tasks,
and the next one is to apply an
encryption policy using Anthos
configuration management.
So check out the Anthos
tutorial and try it on your own.
So this concludes our
demo and presentation,
and we want to leave
you with key takeaways.
So first, Anthos is the hybrid
and multi-cloud platform
for application modernization.
Second, it helps
you productionize
your modern
application environment
based on the common set
of tools such as policies
and service observability
across environments.
Anthos is completely
software based.
It is based on open
source, and so it
removes any type of login,
be it on the environment
or the API being used.
And last, you can
try Anthos today
by taking advantage
of trial options
and by exploring Anthos
with the tutorial.
So here are the related
sessions where you
can get more details on Anthos.
If you have any
follow up questions,
please go ahead and refer to
the Dory for this session.